leute was geht ab hier ist euer granie
und heute gibt es mal eine runde kurze
weile games hab ich gerade beschlossen
so ich bin ein bisschen angeschlagen mal
wieder auf dem kanal meines bruders und
ihr seht vielleicht hat ein neues
mikrofon das allererste mal dass ich
mich diesen mikrofon aufnehmen solche
vergessen vergessen mich umzudrehen
er war schon aktiviert manchmal manchmal
schreibt dass ihr ein bisschen rum man
egal spiel aber ohne nicht
wahrscheinlich wieder zu foto getragen
aber mein bruder hat mich mal wieder
gebeten hatte was für ihn hochladen und
ja ihr seht ihr neues mikrofon ist
gerade eben vor 10 angekommen und ich
mache mich direkt an was auch zu nehmen
sind sehr gut und ich bin durch
blutkontakt bekommen
rosberg holt diesmal und klimaforschung
was gehört aber die wollten halt die
jeder ungefähr diese ode in der 1a
kaufen aber es war schon mal leider aus
was immer so ein bisschen schlimmer die
aufmerksamkeit darauf die fußballer
alter wert den so ne kiste übersehen oh
gott nein er geht ihr könnt mich nicht
erwünscht ok dann kommt erst jetzt nicht
gut ausgerüstet
konrad bitter dass die leute jetzt hat
mich gehen weil ich keine ecke
wir wollten gewinnen konnte aber ja da
hab ich mir das mikrofon gekocht von
luca in hongkong kraft
ein guter sex ist definitiv und ich kann
es auch weiter empfehlen
ich kann auch beide empfehlen und ich
weiß gar nicht ob man es ja auch wieder
so penetrant raus hat das dass sich die
tastatur gewaltigen ein bisschen wenn
ich zocken aber ansonsten muss man
einfach damit leben
weil ja davon machen wie ich auf jeden
fall team stören
gut für einen teil schon mal rauskommen
und dann ein wenig wind einen einnehmen
wird eine ich mit an dem ich mit putzen
gute spieler sehr männlich wenn man im
nächsten game city macht also das ist
schon respekt diesmal doch
komischerweise das mittlerin
funktioniert deshalb gehen wir über die
nächste runde
wir machen einfach mal ein kurzes video
heute acht minuten war ich für mich auch
noch wasser aufnehmen wollte deshalb ist
das entweder letzteren voller zone jetzt
hier noch kommen wird und ich bin vor
allem und der schönheit diese mikrofons
angetan ich bin ich wirklich ziemlich
geil aus
also in der keim nicht so guten von
tonnen
aber es wäre heute ein top-trainer dabei
der halt zu geben was klein ist
probieren und wir schreiben die
kommentare ob man sich sehr stark machen
weil der bisschen pop wieder da und
ihnen diese laute bisschen besser
klingen zu lassen bisschen weniger
schrecklich
sie haben fitness ich war gut drin
einfach irgendwann zu sehen
manchmal stehe ich mir den abbau von
obwohl ich gelegt werden dass leute mich
tagen und dann denke ich mir dann immer
wieder okay vielleicht wirst du doch
nicht so ausgeprägt ist wie du manchmal
denkst aber es ist schon relativ häufig
das schicksal teilt man wenn man youtube
ist alles klar als klar ist klar gesagt
kurs mikrofon
er könnte eigentlich so gar nicht sagen
hat hat er einen spin werte tatsächlich
der berufs panzer darunter gut wie der
erste kampf mit dem gegen dem mit dem
schwert war ganz gut ich bin einfach
gesprungen weil man dann steht er
schneller schlagen kann ich mehr
sprinten also manchmal gerichtet hat
und er hat fehler gemacht dass er das
nicht gemacht hat und deshalb konnte ich
locker easyjet sind aber wir sind wohl
egal ich mache das ganze ist erbe antrat
ging es ohne und irgendwann bald hat
mein bruder auch wieder die möglichkeit
selbst aufzunehmen und zwar wenn er
hierher kommt nach die stadt wo ich
wohne fast schon wieder so dünn gewesen
jetzt verraten
oft passiert dass ich dann aus dem video
rausschneiden musste ich immer wieder
sage er kommt wieder und dann seht ihr
auch mal jemand anders ich habe ihn
schon und zwar schlecht gehen weil ich
könnte mir gut vorstellen dass es mit
meiner maus zusammenhängt in der mitte
getauscht er wird sie eine maus weil ich
seine auswahl noch bei mir im rucksack
also als er als er gefahren ist dann
hatte ich sein was noch
aber das war auf jeden fall funktioniert
bis zur mitte ist wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen viel zeit nach vorn aber so
da und ein paar menschen
noch immer sterben
hierbei hat bei den niederländern
entscheidend
bisschen
da reingehen dieses flugzeug war
da hab ich jetzt hier zu folgen
letzte runde in wie ich ohne aufnahme
später mit 68 war ein zu dem diesmal
wenig schaffen
nicht
hopfen
schon trocken
aggro berliner alter chef hat die frist
bis kennt dann viel benzin an
und sagt dann
dass die liebsten die angreifen wenn man
irgendwie sowas aus wie wenn man was
aussortiert und dann abhauen wenn man
wenn man sie bemerkt dass es wirklich
geht auf dem niedrigsten level also
probiert sozusagen abzustauben und so
weiter dann merkt dass es nicht geht
heute direkt wieder auf ein schiff
da ist auch schon der lieber kerl der
das rennen gemacht hat nie das war der
gleiche
spannend spannend letzte ohne auf jeden
fall man zumindest diese runde gewinnen
ein bisschen was kehliges habt bestimmt
wieder die leute oder beim einen kanal
die leute kommen irgendwo konto mensch
sagst du was geht und so eine scheiße
aber man kann darauf haben uns so was
nicht wirklich braucht traurigerweise
also ich finde es wirklich einfach stumm
zu sagen nur auf heißen buchstäblicher
sind die spieler auch besser aber es ist
trotzdem nicht geschenkt wenn man auch
beim hd hier ein bisschen besser ist
über ping und so
tübingen mit aussieht
die volle akkus nicht hier mal die
wahrscheinlichkeit geht wenn die mit den
nummern können
wir suchen unsere nächsten gegner auf
jeden fall
wer von euch also auch funktionieren
ein bisschen feedback heißt wie der
dingo finden weil ich bin definitiv nach
den ersten paar soundchecks
unterzubringen überlegen
zum rap machen wie das paddel gemacht
hat oder dass ganz viele andere machen
trocken aber machen wir ein fass auf pc
eingestellt
also 14 boxen wer führt man den
doppelten liege
gut gemachtes kelly grunde
er schreibt einfach
genau ich hab svm mein lieber ist auch
gut wenn leute immer schreibt anhalt
text wenn man jemand gut kate als dann
gehe ich erstmal fünf selber mutter und
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen ich muss
mal kurz mal mikrofon zum abschied und
nachts gut